hi you were at Vision at the Met Gala
darling in your business tonight honey
thank you I've got my glitter on you
in the favor have fun and dance tonight
thank you are you so proud of this woman
always
oh loves in the air at the Academy of
Country Music Awards Thursday with
celebrity couples making it the perfect
date night
first time hosting it's happening very
soon buddy has he been reciting some
lines with nutrition he's been um
walking pacing a lot which means I know
he's really thinking about it and
nervous a little bit nervous but it's
gonna be great from Trisha Yearwood
supporting her man Garth Brooks to newly
engaged Cole Swindell and Courtney
little raving over their sweet moment
[Applause]
I got a special one and we could not be
more excited I'm already a winner before
I even got here
absolutely
you could you blacked out when you were
proposing this I mean wouldn't anybody
yeah I uh but hey she said yes and we're
we're good but it's uh an honored to be
here just tonight and Elaine Wilson
showing off on the carpet all right she
made her red carpet debut with former
Pittsburgh Steelers quarterback Devlin
duck Hodges yep yep I brought me a hot
date tonight I sure did I mean he
looking like a a snack over there ain't
he a little snack of a cowboy I know I'm
like you know what I said you can be my
date but you can't steal my thunder so
and I was like Hey look look at all
these cameras don't be nervous boy
[Music]